sur le fond le projet doit via et noble
puisqu'il veut interdire entre autres
les contenus haineux racistes ou
terroristes mais sur la forme c'est là
que ça se complique
certaines mesures proposées sont très
difficile voire quasiment impossible à
appliquer elle si elle l'était elle
porterait atteinte à la liberté
d'expression d'une manière ou d'une
autre
une déception pour celle qui porte ce
projet doit depuis le début elle
laetitia via une députée a l'air est
mise en cause dans plusieurs affaires
assez délicate
l'intéressé aurait notamment d'après
d'anciens collaborateurs tenu des propos
racistes sexistes et homophobes
alors quand on regarde d'un peu plus
près les décisions du conseil on réalise
que c'est l'essence même de la loi qui a
été censuré
le conseil constitutionnel a rejeté
plusieurs mesures l'une d'entre elles
concerne obligation faite aux réseaux
sociaux de supprimer le contenu haineux
dans les 24 heures sous peine de
sanctions pénales
un délai jugé trop court à appliquer
pour les administrateurs la peine prévue
était lourde en cas de non respect par
l'hébergeur ou l'éditeur un an
d'emprisonnement et 250000 euros damende
alors on le sait est des millions de
messages sont publiés chaque jour sur
les réseaux sociaux et faire un grand
ménage en l'espace d'une journée relève
de la mission impossible
et puis pour éviter des sanctions cette
mesure aurait pu pousser les
responsables à censurer tout et
n'importe quoi à partir du moment où un
signalement avait eu lieu et c'est
l'opposition qui se réjouit de cette
nouvelle écoute et lourde défaite pour
belloubet la loi via contre la haine en
ligne est quasi entièrement censurée par
le conseil constitutionnel
la volonté liberticide en échec la loi
via très largement censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel suite à la
saisine du groupe et l'air au sénat il
n'y a quasiment que le titre qui est
constitutionnel
la censure ne sera pas confiée aux gars
femmes tous ceux qui sont attachés à la
liberté devrait s'en réjouir
ce texte de loi est vivement critiquée
depuis le tout début notamment par le
conseil national numérique ou encore est
la commission consultative des droits de
l'homme
les géants du web eux étaient restés
plutôt discrets
du projet et ils sont finalement les
grands vainqueurs de ce revers infligé à
la majorité maintenant c'est presque un
retour à la case départ pour laetitia
via puisque cette loi ne peut être ni
signée par le président de la république
ni être promulguée résultat des courses
il ne reste plus grand chose de ce
projet la députée l om va donc devoir se
retrousser les manches et présenter un
nouveau texte